Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters, and in this video I'm going to
explain a little bit why someone would choose to purchase the Syrex Array 11, and that is the chemical
immune reactivity screen to see
different chemicals that were exposed to that could have problems in our body. Let's go over that a little bit.
So there's
different arrays in this Syrex choices, so what should I get? It can be complicated. Array 11 is
looking at toxic chemicals that were exposed to. Toxic chemicals is we're going to review
and that causing immune issues. They can cause loss of immune tolerance. We can have reaction to
these chemicals. We can have a reaction to these metabolites. The chemicals can settle in the cells
we can develop antibodies to our cells. It can be ultimately a damage, you know, a cause damage to
gut microbiota. It can damage blood-brained barriers. It can damage just it could cause all
sorts of problems. Nobody's going to argue in this planet that we're exposed to a lot of different
chemicals. Many more chemicals that are ancestors were ever exposed to and that these chemicals
could settle in our bodies in damage, cell membranes, damage barriers, gut barriers, lung barriers,
skin barriers, and brain barriers. And then if that takes place, the immune reaction could take place
and we could end up with a lot of problems. So the reason why you do array 11 is to look at those
toxic chemicals. Array 2 is looking at intestinal barrier issues and where there could be damage in
an intestinal barrier. Array 20 is looking at the blood-brained barriers. So you can combine these
tests. So I'm going to run on array 11. I also want to see where my intestinal barrier is. I also
want to see where my blood-brained barrier is. I'm concerned with dementia issues or possible MS issues.
I don't want to end up with Alzheimer's like my mom or Parkinson's disease where things are
getting across the blood-brained barrier that are causing inflammation or damaging
cells or at worst-case scenario developing antibodies to neural tissue. Now that would be seen,
do I have antibodies to neural tissue? That would be seen in array 7 and array 7x. I prefer the array 7x.
It's more complete. But if you suspect immune autoimmune issues, I highly recommend you also run
array 5 and we'll have another video and explain that. Array 6 ties in diabetic type possibilities
as well and array 8 more specific joint autoimmune reactivities. But array 5 gives you a more complex
picture of autoimmune issues. And then we'll talk about another video on array 12 which talks about
pathogens. That's, you know, a lot of people think that they have chronic Lyme and that's my
issue with chronic Lyme. Well, did these pathogens end up creating an immune reaction in your body?
Well, you can find out with going through the going with that array. So with Cyrex, I know it gets
costly to run too many things. On a perfect world, if this was all covered by your insurance or if it
was all free, well, good to say, we'd run everything and take a look at that. But we just got to pick
and choose what's most common or most probable issue in my life that I want to take a look at
and make our choices wisely. So through a case review, I'll help you walk through that decision-making
process and I'll help make specific recommendations for you. So I just wanted you to know if I made
this recommendation for array 11, why we would look at it. When we're exposed to toxins in our
environment, it can cause a loss of what we call an immune tolerance. We decrease our immune tolerance
or immune system is less able to deal with things, the more toxic insult that we have. So more and more
exposures to poisons or pathogens, toxins in our environment ends up creating in a loss of
immune tolerance and then our body can actually create antibodies to self-dissue and that's what an auto-immune
disease is. This takes time. It's not necessarily or rarely unless it's a huge poisonous
act that you're exposed to. But it happens over time. We build up these things in our system. We think,
okay, well, by having I got rid of this mercury toxicity from when I was eight years old and had
mercury fillings, I had all those removed. Well, these things have a half life of like 15 million years.
They're not going anywhere. So if you're not detoxing them out of your body and pulling them out of your
body and we'll talk about that at the end of this video, then they're staying there and there could
cause issues as time goes by. So what really happens when chemicals enter our body, they're metabolized
through our cytochrome P450 and PUN1 and that pathways in the liver and they end up as an
approach tied to that metabolite ends up becoming an antigen-presenting cell to the immune system,
creates a T cell reaction. Well, our T cells, natural killer cells,
lipocytes going to kill these things. No, they're not living organisms. So then we fire a B cell
reaction. We start to create antibodies. And that's what we can measure. So we can measure those
antibodies, what we're exposed to, what we're currently dealing with in our body. That's why with
Cyrex, they do a IgG plus IgA and an IgM, many of these because many people will create different
types of antibodies depending upon their body and how their bodies react into these toxins. So we
have to measure all those antibodies. That's why I like the Cyrex test because it looks at all these
different types of antibodies. So when we have xenomionic exposure that's exposure to poisons and
toxins in our environment, they themselves will cause oxidative stress. So what does oxidative stress
do and activates T cells and macrophages and causes this pro-inflammatory cytokine response? So you
end up with all these pro-inflammatory, inflammatory markers and inflammatory chemokines and inflammatory
cytokines that are created that can damage cells and long-term inflammation can damage. If these are
inside the cell and they're causing this inflammatory response, these can be a cause of cancers. These can
be a cause of mitochondrial dysfunction. They can be a cause of just chronic fatigue. If it gets
inside the brain, it can be a cause of depression. So when we're looking at these causes, you go to the
standard medical doctor. They're just going to give you a drug to kind of, oh, you got depression,
here, take this or you got fatigue. Take this and we're not getting to the root of the issue and that's
what we have to get at. Zeno-biotic exposure also, depending on your genetic susceptibility, that
means depending on the health of your cytokine P450 or P1 pathways and your net pathways and all your
liver pathways that are supposed to metabolize these things and get rid of them. And when we have
issues with our barrier, so if we already have issues with our skin barrier, our lung barrier,
our gut barrier, our brain barrier, these things get across the gut membrane. They get across these
membranes and they can damage other tissues. So I mentioned, it gets across the blood brain barrier,
it gets inside the brain. Now, your brain immune system, your microglial cells have to deal with this.
It can damage the microglial cells, cause microglial primate and worst case scenario, damage the
different neural cells and cause an autoimmune response so you're actually making antibodies to
different neural cells. Friends, that's what MSNs, you know, you have an antibody break, antibodies
against neural cells that you're breaking down and destroying self tissue. So Zeno-biotic exposure
also creates chemical bonds to proteins and forms what are called DO antigens, which they themselves
activate B cells. What do B cells do? They make antibodies. So this is a pathway to developing
autoimmunity. So we need to deal with these things. They're not something like, oh, you're just
poopoo this stuff. This is a major cause of problems. So the purpose of the array 11 is to identify
loss of immune tolerance. Have we developed antibodies to these things already?
They, it gives us guidelines that, okay, we need to start detoxing this. Before we have an autoimmune
disease. So it's not measuring self antibody. So it's not measuring, do you have an autoimmune
disease yet? That's array 5, that's array 7x. But it's, it's seen, do you already, are you making
antibodies against poisons that because you've been so exposed? So who would want to get this
test is that we know that we have chronic health conditions. We're trying to discover what those
chronic health conditions could be, could have been caused from. So this is looking at purpose
of this test is to dig to cause. So you know, if you listen to me, that's what I'm all about. Let's
get to the cause. Let's try to correct that. So our body, which is made in the image of God,
can start healing from the inside out. We need to start cleaning those things out so that we can
deal with it. That's the purpose of this. So it's going to measure all these different tests. We're
going to touch on a few of them, trying to make this video short. So I don't worry to death, but we
want, we want to test these different chemicals. And you're like, I can't even, you know, you know,
I don't even understand what those are. Well, I see what mercury compounds, I know what that is,
are heavy metals. But one of these other things, let's dig into it just a wee bit. All these chemicals
are chemicals that you're exposed to. Every single person is exposed to these things on a daily basis.
So we understand that this isn't something like, oh, I don't work at a chemical factory or, you know,
so this isn't my issue. You're exposed to this, even if you're trying to live this really healthy
lifestyle and not eat anything not organic and do everything right. Sorry, we live in a toxic world
that's used to using, you know, toxins to, to make our life simpler. And it just is what it is.
There's just no getting away from a lot of these things. So here would be an example of a test.
This person has, so everything green would be normal. Anything in yellow is, you already are making
antibodies. Anything in red is just equivalently further out of rage. So anything in yellow
red is positive. So this has, this person has iso cyanate antibodies and benzene ray
compound antibodies. Well, what the word is that? Well, iso cyanates are a family of highly reactive
low molecular weight chemicals used in foams, fibers, paints, artiches, elastomers, anything in the
automobile industry, auto body repair, building insulation materials, many spray on polyurethane
products have iso cyanates in them. Things that are used commercially to protect cement or
wood or fiberglass or steel or aluminum. Do you have these things in your house? Hello? Yes,
everybody does. You cannot have this these poisons in our house. It's a matter of whether, again,
going back, understanding your normal detoxification process, whether you are able to get rid of that
or not. Remember, if you have these things in your system, you were either exposed to a higher
amount of them at one time than your ability to get rid of them at that given time. That's what
happened, or you were exposed over time to a lot of them, and your body just can't get rid of them.
If your toxic, your rate of toxicification, your rate of exposure exceeds your rate of detoxification,
you're going to be toxic. So, it's not a matter of I'm going to do this box detox and I'm
going to get rid of all this stuff. No, I'm all better. This isn't the work that way. You have to
be constantly getting rid of these things, supporting those pathways in the liver, and beyond that,
when we talk about the seven pathways of detoxification, we need to support all those pathways so that you
can get them out of you and into the toilet and out of your body. That's the goal of this.
The other thing, so run this test, we're going to break these things down so you'll know where you're
exposed to these things. Where are benzene ring compounds found? Well, they're found in crude oil,
they're found in gasoline, your pulpy gas on a weekly basis probably,
they're solvents, especially rubber and surface coating materials. Benzene rings are
everywhere. So, we're exposed to benzene. I remember back in organic chemistry class, we use benzene
as a as a cleaner. Whenever we did a chemistry experiment, we claimed things with benzene.
But it states, we're exposed to benzene. I got out of my hands. Everything, you know, you're
breathing this stuff in. It is a chemical solvent that can't use it that way anymore, but
we're exposed to benzene in a lot of different ways. And then, here's another test tip, you're
positive with bisphenol A. Where is that? That's in plastics. There's a new study out that shows there's
even bisphenol A and BPAs in plastics that say that they're BPA-free.
You can't get away from this stuff. Apoxys, dental sealants, compactus, slackers,
they're coated food cans, canned foods, coated in bottle caps, coated of canned sodas,
thermal receipt paper. How can you like live your life? Not being exposed to some of these chemicals.
Does it mean that just because we're exposed to these chemicals that we're going to have positive tests?
No, it doesn't. But if your rate of toxicification exceeds your rate of detoxification,
you're going to be toxic. So, you're some of the other examples of positive tests. Where would
these things be phoned? Well, tetra, bromo, bisphenol A is phoned. It's a derivative bisphenol A
found in electric circuit boards. And here's the big one, as a flame retardant in foam. These
flame retardants, you're going to see this over and over as flame retardants. The government
passed a law that children's clothing has to be sprayed with flame retardant or you have to buy
organic children's clothing. And it's like, you buy a new couch? Guess what? It's sprayed with
flame retardant. I had a co-worker one time that their son was having issues. We can't remember
the issues as a number of years ago, tested them. He tested sensitive to flame retardants and
where was he getting flame retardants? They said, no, we only buy organic clothes, but we all
we bought a new couch and he's been sleeping on the couch. Well, you're exposed to flame retardants
from that all new furniture. The material is flame retardants. This is a huge issue that people
don't even think of. So I'm not going to read all these other things, but you can see that, you know,
these things are found in everyday life. That's my point of this. And if we run this test on you
and there's things that are in yellow and red, we're going to give you these spec sheets so you can
understand where I could be exposed to these things, because we could detoxify these things,
and that's the goal. We want to completely detoxify these things, and we want to have a test that
looks like this. But the truth is, is that if you're constantly exposed to these things, your rate of
toxicification is going to be higher than your ability to detoxify these things, and you're going to
be making yourself sicker and sicker and sicker. So it's a good idea to run this test to go,
oh my gosh, this is way off the chart. I want to pull this out, but I want to know where I could have
been exposed to this. Sometimes you're never going to be able to figure that out, but sometimes you're
going to go, oh my gosh, this is what I'm exposed to at work all the time. I'm going to stop doing
that activity or whatever it is. You got to put on your Sherlock hat and do a little investigation
and figure this out. Again, people, if you don't take responsibility for your health, nobody's
going to do that. Is your standard doctor going to do these kind of tests? No, you are listening
to this video because you're trying to take responsibility for your health and your family's health.
Now, I understand when we talk about detoxification, I'm not talking about here, just take this pill,
it's going to go away. I have to understand the seven phases of detoxification. That's why we created
a whole course about it. At least download the book. It's for you who have been in this alternative
space for a long period of time. These are going to be, you're going to have some aha moments that
read the book or study the seven phases course. But if you're not dealing with all those downstream
things and making sure that you're having good bowel movements every single day, making sure that
you're binding stuff in the gut so that you're not reabsorbing stuff, making sure that your
gallbladder is working well and that you're not blocking the release of these toxins in the
gallbladder and reabsorbing things, making sure your three phases of the liver are healthy. You
don't have no business to start pulling stuff out of the tissue until you do that first.
I explain that in detail in that book and in that course. I get that this is a giant spider web
that we're dealing with. But you cannot start to get healthy. It's how we start to break this down
and to figure this out. That's why we run tests. You don't know unless you can see and then it helps
you understand then so that you know how to move forward. And that's what our goal is. Again,
I believe that verse study to show yourself approved is not just for scripture to show yourself
approved to be able to witness the people. But it's to know how to take care of yourself and your
family. We've been taught in this country just to push this responsibility onto a doctor or something.
And I'm here to try to push this responsibility back to you and empower you to be able to make
the right decisions. All right. Have a great day.